protests at more than a dozen clark
county schools
it's part of a call by many parents to
bring all not some students back to the
classroom
soon pre-k through third grade children
are expected back on campus march first
bianca holman reports from one of
several rallies across the valley
cheers and waves in front of foothill
high school parents and students here
want
all students to have the option to
return to school and activities
these rallies come after a recent ccsd
survey in which parents had only
two options to choose from either their
kids will learn virtually
or learn through the hybrid model
parents fear that ccsd will use the
information as an outline for not only
the spring semester
but also the start of school in august
elijah and kylie are high school seniors
who don't want to be forgotten
they say learning online is frustrating
at times making it hard to reach their
full potential
so if they let us get back into school
it'll be a lot easier to learn
and plus if we get sports back
everyone's grades will go up
because that's a lot of people that's
the reason they do good in school is
because of sports
we should be setting the pace not
following the pack
we're nevada step forward we're the
silver state
battle born let's get going currently
ccsd has no plans of allowing kids back
into the classroom full time
parents here want this topic to be
discussed at the next ccsd board meeting
reporting from college and horizon drive
bianca holman
8 news now